des mesures diplomatiques pour sauver un
accord nucléaire important pour les
équilibres internationaux etats unis
iran la guerre des mots et le poids des
âmes dans les paroles et les promesses
sont inutiles cette fois ci des actes de
l'action et si nous voyons des actes de
la part de la partie en face alors nous
agirons aussi la république islamique ne
se contentera pas cette fois-ci de
parole et de promesses que nous ferons
ceci ou cela ce ne sera pas comme avant
nous avons toujours dit que nous
attendons de l'iran qu'il respecte à
nouveau les engagements qu'il a suspendu
petit à petit et que nous sommes prêts à
l'aider en tant qu'européens et que
d'autre part la politique de sanctions
qu'il ya eus sous le présent trump
appartient également au passé
aujourd'hui les plus grandes nations du
monde sont concernés après une
concertation entre français britannique
allemand et américain
washington a accepté de participer à de
futures négociations avec l'union
européenne et téhéran dans l'espoir de
raviver les accords de 2015 il s'agit de
s'asseoir à une table avec l'iran et
ouvrir une voie pour essayer de revenir
à une situation où les états unis et
l'iran seront à nouveau en conformité
l'administration maiden a donc décidé de
rompre avec les dernières mesures prises
par donald trump et son souhait d'un
renforcement des sanctions
internationales contre la république
islamique
une lettre a été adressée ainsi en ce
sens au conseil de sécurité de l'onu le
département d'état a annoncé également
jeudi que les diplomates iraniens seront
désormais autorisés à se déplacer
librement à new york ce vendredi le
ministre iranien des affaires étrangères
a réitéré son appel à une levée de
toutes les sanctions imposées par
l'ancien président républicain les etats
unis ont reconnu que les revendications
de mac pompéo concernant la résolution
22 30 et une n'avait aucune validité
juridique
nous sommes d'accord en conformité avec
la résolution 22 30 et une les états
unis lèvent sans condition et de manière
effective toutes les sanctions
prononcées réimposées
ou réétiqueter par trump nous annulerons
alors immédiatement toutes les mesures
correctives objectifs de washington
empêchait toujours l'iran d'enrichir de
l'uranium dans le but d'acquérir une
arme nucléaire téhéran qui a annoncé
cette semaine mettre fin aux inspections
surprise de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique dans le cadre de
l'accord de 2015 le directeur de
l'agencé onusienne est attendu ce samedi
dans la capitale iranienne